bu
Süren çok az motor gibi anlatacağım
Hazırsanız başlıyorum bu işlere Ben
nasıl ulaştım önce biraz ondan
başlayalım sonra Kuran hikayesini
anlatacağım ve bu günlere geldik ne
yapıyoruz ne ediyoruz niye yapıyoruz
bunları onlardan bahsedeceğim Aslında bu
da kimse benim bir koro şefi müzisyen ya
da besteci olacağını düşünüyorum çok
küçük yaşlardayken Çünkü iki buçuk
yaşındayken kendi kendime Okuma Yazma
Öğreniyorum dolaştı ailenin benim
üzerimdeki hep hayali ve ideali herhalde
geleceğin parlak bilim insanı yönünde
bir şey ama bir yandan da bir oyuncak
melodika ile karşılaşıp bu sefer onda
kendi kendime Duyduğum her şey çalmaya
başlamıştım bunu farkedince
Bizimkilerden ufak bir org alıyorlar bu
sefer orada vardır küçük ordular olan
aranızda Muhtemelen bölümde sarı sarı
tuşları vardır Tüh falan diye davul seti
simülasyonu olan sonra Oo bitince bir
büyü geldi derken böyle bir böyle
başlayan bir müzik yaşantısı Uzunca bir
süre de zaten kendi kendine devam edecek
bu o okuma yazma ve sayılarla aram iyi o
yüzden hep okul yaşadım Çok ilginç geçti
işte yuva anasınıfı işte İlkokul
İlköğretim diyim bütün bu aşamalarda hep
bir sınıf atlatma girişimi annemin
enişte yaşıtlarıyla okusun edilmesiyle
sonuçlanan ki çok mantıklı buluyorum
hala bir süreç Herkes başıma toplanırdı
böyle işte kağıdıma bakardı hocalar
böyle kağıtları dağıttı zaman yazılar
sonrasında a hata yapmış hocam hata
yapmış gibi gibi bundan Bana kalan bir
mükemmeliyetçilik oldu büyük şans
travmatik bir şey dönmedi Ama yaptığım
bütün işlerde Muhtemelen işte kusursuz
olmaya olabildiğince hatasız
olabildiğince en iyi yapmaya kendin bir
şekilde şartlanmış bir çocuk olarak
yetiştim derslerle Okulla aran hep çok
iyi oldu gelirdim Evet çantamı
bırakırdım hemen işte 20-30 dakika
Ödevlerimi bitirdim Daha üniformanın
çıkarmadan Ondan sonra Kendimi dışarı
atarım ya bir modern dans provası şey ya
bir halk oyunları çalışması o var bunun
bir antrenmanı işte ya da bir satranç
çalışması vesaire aklınıza gelecek envai
çeşit hobi diyebileceğimiz ama benim bir
şekilde hobi gözüyle yaklaşamadığı
birçok aktivite hiçbir şey yoksa ya
Mahallede Park vardı bir tane çok geniş
bir park çıkıp orada çok güzel maçlar
yapardık Yani bunlara yetişen bir çocuk
olduğu için çok mutluyum ve bu hiçbir
şeyi yalnızca hobi işte Hadi biraz da
şunu dediğim gibi yaklaşmayı PDA hepsini
çok ciddiye alarak ve lâyıkıyla yapmak
bana keyif verdiği içinde asla yine
bugün hepsinden bir şeyler kaldı lisede
tiyatro Mesela benim için çok çok ön
plandaydı müzikte kendi kendine devam
ediyor 7 yaşında kilise korosunda şarkı
söylemeye başladım 17 yıl kadar orada
şarkı söyledim orada kendi kendime nota
Okumayı Öğrendim ve çok sesli müziği
Aslında içeri değiştirebilme nin en
büyük etkeni odur diyebilirim ya
Türkiye'de çok sesli müziği
içselleştirme Bilmem deki en büyük pay
sahibi şey bir yandan işte lisede çok
yoğun tiyatro ile ilgileniyorum bir okul
grubumuz oldu Ben onlarla İşte o kendi
kendime öğrendiğim Klavye çalmak nota
okumak işte şarkı söylemek birikimi de
kullanarak düzenlemeler yapardım şarkı
söyler demişti klavye gitar çalardım
biraz onlarla da liselerarası birçok
Festival yarışmaya katıldık güzel
ödüller aldık bunlardan bir tanesi hasta
beni Boğaziçi Üniversitesi ile
tanıştıran yarışma Battle Of The
benziyor bir yarışma hiç duyanınız var
mı bilmiyorum ama dönemin önemli amatör
müzik grupları yarışmalarından biri
belki de yayınlanması Manga Gripin gibi
şimdi tanıdığımız grupların böyle
birinci olup da oradan işte müzik
yolculuklarına ciddi kariyerlerine
başladıkları bir yarışma yaş ortalaması
işte 30-35 böyle Türkiye'nin her
yerinden amatör müzik grupları
profesyonel müzisyenler de var içlerinde
Bizler ise grubunuzda başvurduk
bestelerimi gönderdik Finale kaldık
ve yarışma günü Boğaziçi Üniversitesi'ne
gittim ilk defa kenarda duruyoruz böyle
tıfıl Çocuklar işte el şu anda böyle
gitarlar Klavyeler falan biri geldi
yanımıza dayanamayıp artık dedi ki ya
çocuklar bir şey soracağım Siz ne
yapıyorsunuz burada ya dedim Siz de
yarış maçınız yoksa bizde evet abi
büyük başarının gerçekten yani bu yaşta
finale kalmak Aferin size helal olsun
başımıza okşadı gitti işte aradan bir
5-6 saat geçti yarışmalar yapıldı
sonuçlandı biz 1. olduk soru yarışmadı
sonra başımız okuyan kişi daha görmedik
ve ve o şekilde ben Boğaziçi
Üniversitesi'nde tanıştım Aslında
Boğaziçi Üniversitesi'nde okumak hep
hayalimdi Ama herhangi bir şey okuyup da
işte bir işte ne bileyim bilmem ne
mühendisliği okuyup şöyle bir yerde
yüksek lisans ettiğim şöyle bir işim
şöyle bir evin şöyle Arabam şey bir
Kariyerim olsun gibi ve fikirle değil de
gerçekten üniversite yaşantısı benim
için çok küçük yaştan ilginç bulurum
bunu
hala da arkasındayım bu bilincin benim
için bir meslek kapısından ziyade
Aslında evimizden uzaklaştığımız ve
Türkiye bu dünyanın dört bir yanından
bambaşka stiller de insanlarla
karşılaştığımız farklı Hayat
görüşlerinden farklı ailelerde yetişmiş
farklı hassasiyetleri olan birçok farklı
insanla karşılaşıp kendimizi
keşfettiğimiz ufkumuzu vizyonumuzu
şekillendirdiğimiz karakterimizi Aslında
oluşturduğumuz şekillendirdiğimiz ve
bizi bi ergenlikten genç yetişkinliğe
doğru
ulaştıracak bir köprü yani işte 17 16 17
yaşındayken de böyle düşünüyordum Bunun
sebebi de Ailemin bana ekonomik rahatlık
sağlaması vesaire değil tam tersi her
zaman kendi hayatını kazanması gerektiği
bilinciyle yetişen bir çocuk oldu ve
böyle boğaz Üniversitede okumaya
başladım ne okusam beni keser dedim
Eledim eledim eledim psikoloji ve
matematik kaldı sayısal bölüm okuyordum
matematik kazandım başladım okumaya
devlete İstanbul radyosu çoksesli
gençlik korosunda şarkı söylemeye
başladım ardından
bir yandan da birçok grupta çalıyorum
liseden devam eden tiyatro grubumuz var
mezunları Ben onlarla devam ediyorum
Zaten acayip yoğun bir yaşantım olmuş
yani üniversiteye gelene kadar ve
üniversitede baktım ki Müzik Kulübü
Barbie müzik Kulübü'nün koroları var Hep
korolarda söyleyen çocuk olarak ben de
bir tanesi neden yer almıyorum deyip
tanışma gününde dinletisine denk geldim
cihaz konusunu seçmelerine girdim
kazandım başladım söylemeye iki yıl
orada şarkı söylerken o zaman keyfimiz
Cihan'ın asistanlığını yaptım Bir nevi
İşte o zamana kadar getirdim o kendi
kendime edindiğim müzik birikimiyle
diyeyim iki yıl sonra Cihan Amerika'ya
gitmeye karar verdi ve konuda bir ne
devretmesi gerekecek bana teklif etti bu
sorumluluğu Ben de mutlulukla ve gururla
kabul ettim dedim ki
çok teşekkür ederim ama bir şey yapmak
istiyorum Seninde rızan alarak yeni
baştan bir seçme yapmak istiyorum evdeki
çok laf söyleyecekler çok önüne
çıkacaklar Yani neden yeni baştan seçme
yapılıyor korunun içindekilere bir daha
seçmemi olur yok dedim Ha ben başka
türlü rahat etmeyeceğim işte çocuktan
gelen bir huyu var ya bir şey olacaksa
en iyisi olacak ha o öğrenci kulübü
etkinliği yani Boğaziçi Üniversitesi
Müzik Bölümü yok Bu arada bir çoğunuz
biliyordur Muhtemelen
Tamam dedi ben senin yanındayım yaptık
yeni baştan bir seçme 2007 yılı Bıdı
dokuz kişi başladık ben de söylüyorum ve
topluluğun içinde o ilk performans bir
buçuk ay sonra git performans inanılmaz
bir renk uyandırdı o hani yükselen
sesler aşağı indi müthiş bir ilgi oldu
paylaştık bütün performans larımızı
sosyal medyadan 2007'den bahsediyorum 15
yıl önce bu arada sosyal medya denen şey
yani yavaş yavaş bütün üniversitelerden
davetler almaya başladı daha ilk
yılımızda İstanbul Caz Festivali Akbank
Caz Festivali Eskişehir Anadolu
Üniversitesi amatör caz müzisyenleri
Festivali gibi heyecanlı içinde hem de
birçok farklı yerde farklı festivalde
performanslar yaptık Avusturya'da çok
önemli ve AKP ile yarışmasında 2 Gümüş
diploma kazandık döndük
3-4 yıl üniversite çatısı altında çok
fazla şey yaptık farklı ekiplerle
değişen topluluklarla farklı da 3D Jazz
ağırlıklı ama bir yandan da son iki
yılımızda da içine çoksesli türküler
dünya el literatüründen farklı
dönemlerden eserler katmaya başladı
çünkü 2010'da Çin'e gitmeye karar verdik
dünya kor Olimpiyatları'na büyük
zorluklarla kimse inanmıyordu
gideceğimize son saniye kadar direndik
bir şekilde bütçeyi toparlayıp gittik 90
ülke
400 pro-v 30 bine yakın katılımcıyla
gerçekleşen dünyanın en büyük horozu
etkinliği yılda bir düzenleniyor
Dünyanın farklı yerlerinde Tabi orada da
acayip bir şeyle karşılaştık bir
ikincilik iki üçüncülük kazandı Koş çok
önemli etkinlikte döndük Türkiye 2011
dünya şampiyonasına gitmek istiyor Bu
sefer Avusturya'da paramız yok ne
yapacağız ne edeceğiz işte bir buçuk ay
kalmış yarışmaya her neredeyse haftada
2-3 konserimiz var iyice artık popüler
leştir yani o zamandan bir kitle
oluşmuştu İşte bu videoda izlediğiniz
Metro videosu videonun başında
izlediğiniz kaçınız o videoyu Haziran
2011'de acaba gördüğü Denk geldiniz bu
videosunu daha önce izleyenler var mı
bayağı bir el var O herhalde Bozacağız
konusunu o vesileyle tanışmış oldunuz
ilk karşılaşmamız öyleydi birçoğunuzun
diyeyim İşte o video Aslında biz
kendimize sponsor ararken şampiyona
gidebilmek için Türkiye'de bambaşka bir
sayfa açtı
bu hem koro müziği ne hem caz müziği
olan bir Aslında mesafede diyemiyorum
Çünkü halk bilmiyorum müzikleri
Öncelikle halka bunun Böyle çok
eğlenceli bir yönünü tanıtmış oldu Hiç
bilmeyen Kore müziğini böyle tanıdığı
çok sesli koro müziği midir yoksa Koru
larımız var tabii ki yani çok değerli
Türk Halk Müziği koroları süt sanat
müziği koroları mı ama çok sesli koro
müziği ne halk bilmiyordu o zamana kadar
ta ki bu video işte bir anda böyle bir
tam gün boyunca işte İstanbul
Sokaklarında bir arkadaşımızın bir
tanıdığının Nikahına basarak Kadıköy
Evlendirme dairesinden başladığımız en
sonda galiba metroda falan bitti yani o
Saat 8 8.30 gibiydi her bu iş tepkiler
aldık bu günün ardından bir konserimiz
vardı yine işte bilgisayarımı açtım ben
bakıyorum bir sponsorluk dönüşü var mı
acaba bir ümit bir baktım önüme çıktı
video bizim genç yönetmen arkadaşımız
Deniz bizle beraber bütün gün boyunca bu
o da bizdeydi O kendi başına hiç kimseye
sormadan paylaşmış videoyu
20000-30000 50.000 işte 2 3. gün 100.000
o zaman YouTube'da böyle Milyonlar yok
hemen Yani büyük bir izlenme sayısı
Tabii ki hemen işte aynı hafta cuma günü
Beyaz Show cumartesi günü Okan Bayülgen
Disko Kralı vesaire bütün ana haber
bültenleri Kültür Sanat programları
röportajlar derken Türkiye kadın çok
sesli koro müziğinin nasıl bir şey
olduğunu ya da işte gördü tanıdı
Bilenler de başka bir yönünü tanımış
oldu ve biz tam o dönemlerde
üniversiteli artık çok büyük sıkıntılar
yaşamaya başlamıştık ve üniversite
yollarımızı ayırmak durumunda kaldık
şampiyonaya gidebilmek için sponsorumuz
da bulduk O çok zor süreçte gittik Dünya
ama yine videonun başlarında gördüğünüz
iki dünya şampiyonluğu kazanıp
Türkiye'ye döndük yıl
2011/1 ve döndük ama Çalışacak yerimiz
yok ne yapacağız ne edeceğiz kurumlar
farklı dernekler bize kapılarını açtılar
sağolsunlar Çünkü ne seçme yapabiliyoruz
ne prova yapabiliyoruz neredeyse haftada
üç-dört konserimiz oluyor bazen derken
bağımsız bir yolculuk başladı 2012'de
100 bin Euro'luk bir borcun altına
girdik o borcu beş yılda kapata Bildik
yine böyle bir son dakika iptal olan bir
sponsorluk desteği sebebiyle ben o
hazırlığı çöpe atmak istemedim bütün
ikna çabalarına rağmen ve İtalya Amerika
ve macaristan'daki çok önemli
festivallere katıldık altın madalyalarla
döndük ve O risk aldıktan sonra Aslında
orest sayesinde bize dünyanın çok önemli
konu müzik platformlarından dünya
ekonomisini Zirvesi olarak gösterilen
yerlerden davetliler gelmeye başladı
Yani Türkiye'den bir çok sesli koro
Aslında Artık dünyada hatırı sayılır ve
böyle en yüksek seviye platformları Türk
bu temsil eden orada performans
sergileyen ve onların içinden de
Genellikle hep ilk sırada ikinci sırada
ya da en çok dikkat çeken topluluklardan
biri olmaya başarmaya başladı öyle
söyleyin ve
2014'te Boğazı gençlik korusunu kurduk
bu yolculuk devam ederken 2016'da
magmayı kurduk içinden Korolar doğduğu
bütün Bu hikayede bugüne geldiğimiz
zaman Annemi süreci daha dahi bi
yaptığımız seçmelere bir tane seçmeye
Türkiye'nin 81 ilinin yetmişinden
dünyanın bu no 15/16 farklı ülkesinden
30'u Aşkın farklı şehirden bin 350 bin
400 başvuruyu almış bir topluluk haline
geldi Türkiye'de bunların olacağını
bilmiyorum kim düşünebilir dik kimin
aklına gelirdi on yıl öncesinde ama
şimdi öyle bir noktada eski
eski koro müziği mucizesine Anadolu
topraklarına Tüm türkiye'ye yaymayı
kendine misyon edinmiş dün o Anadolu'nun
müziğine en üst düzey popülasyonlarda
başarıyla gururla temsil etmeye devam
eden Hala kendi imkânlarıyla
ve ve şuan bünyesindeki 8 aktif
toplulukla yaşları 65/14 arası değişen
800'e yakın aktif amatör Koru şarkıcısı
bulunan yolu bizden Geçen yine Belki de
4000 kişi vardır öyle söyleyeyim dünyada
desteklediği üniversite korkularıyla
öncülük ettiği projelerle Koru hane
kültürlerin sesi gibi projelerle ki bu
kültürlerin sesiyle beş farklı şehirde
beş farklı dilde şarkı söyleyen Korolar
kurulmasını sağladık birçoğu pandemi
yüzünden askıda kalmış vaziyette ama
bana inanılmaz bir etki yayılıyor Tabii
ki Yani bütün bu projeler ile Tüm
türkiye'ye milyonlarca seveni takipçisi
olan her gün en zor zamanlarda dahi
toplumsal konulara parmak basmaktan ses
çıkarmaktan Bu konularla ilgili
çekinmeye o Milyonlarca kişi her gün
Umut aşılayan ilham olan kocaman bir
aile olduk ne mutlu bize böyle birşey
başarabilecek bütün bu imkansızlıkların
içinde
ama bütün bunları Acaba neden
yapıyorsunuz ya da işte Sen ne yaptın
diye sorarsanız ben matematiği Yarıda
bıraktım müzik okumaya karar verdim Bu
akşam matematiği bıraktım yıldız da bir
yıl okudum orayı bıraktım Mimar Sinan
konservatuar da bir yıl okudum orayı
durdurdum sonra 2013'te bir teşebbüs
daha şimdi hâlâ öğrenciyim
orkestra şefliği lisans okuyorum Sevgili
dostlar varsa aramızda Üniversite
öğrencileri onları selamlamak istiyorum
lisans 2 öğrencisiyim şu an buralarda
olduğum zamanlarda derslerimi
aksatıyorum artık ne yapalım hocalarım
da biraz anlayış gösterecek Zaten yarısı
arkadaşım
ama neden bütün fedakarlığı diye soracak
olursanız altı yıl öncesinden verdiğim
ilginç bir röportaj geçen aylarda
rastladım çok kısa bir kesit
göstereceğim zor da hızlanacağını biraz
70 milyonluk oldu bu ülkede O çok zor mu
Bence değil
bana soruyorlar niye Türkiye'desin niye
yurtdışına gitmiyorsun ne işin var
burada diğer ne var
çok işim var cevap vereceğim
ama gitmek Tabii ki bambaşka kapılar
açan bir şey Orada yaşamak ve bu videoda
icra etmek bütün imkanlar çok daha
yüksek Bütün bunlara rağmen cuburları
farkında kendi niye buradasın diyenler
için de şunu söyleyebilirim
birilerinin burada kalması gerekiyor
bilmiyorum ne düşünüyorsunuz altı yıl
önce bunu söylemişim 6 yıldır buradayım
Ama şu an ne kadar zor değil bu sözün
arkasında durmak zor zor ama birilerinin
kalması gerekiyor gerçekten de ya da
gitsek de dönmemiz yine Burası için bir
şeyler yapmamız gerekiyor başı
gümbürtüye gitti ama iyi de oldu Neden
diye sormuştum ya en başında söylediğim
şey 70 milyonluk bir Koru olabilmek o
zaman öyleydi şimdi 85 milyonluk bir
koro ya neden ne katıyor bize Koru
olabilmek koro müziği yaparken Biz
aslında hep hayalini kurduğumuz
özlediğimiz huzur ve barış içinde
birlikte yaşamayı öğreniyoruz Aslında
birbirimizi dinlemeyi birbirimize
anlayışlı olmayı
farklılıklarımızı birer dezavantajlı
birer zenginlik olarak görüp bu
zenginlik ya bu farklı renklerin
oluşturduğu Harmandan keyif almayı
öğreniyoruz o yüzdendir ki Aslında her
şeye rağmen hâlâ devam ediyoruz gelin
yine pandemi döneminde yaptığımız
röportajlardan derlediğimiz video
o polislerin gözünden çevrimiçi dönemde
katılan arkadaşlarımız var asla yüze
gelmedik bir Koray'a ait olmak ne
demekmiş onların gözünden kulağından
Herşeyden dinleyelim
abone ol
Bu
bir Koray'a ait olmak Yani çok aşırı
güzel bir şey bir kere
[Müzik]
abone ol
bu
[Müzik]
birlikteliğin içine dahil
olabiliyorsunuz ve sen de onlar gibi
baka Biliyorsun aslında ve bence insanın
çakrasını çok geniş yapmışım Çünkü gerek
kültürel olsun gerek yani yaptıklarını
söylediklerini öğrendiklerimizi
diğerlerinin parçasıymış gibi
hissettiriyor
aynı dili konuşabildiğini insanlarla
olduğumu düşünüyorum Bir de şey çok
güzeldi ait böyle DC gerilim vardır ama
iPhone işe vardır gün vardır saçma sapan
geyikleri doğru gider bazen her şeyi ama
bazen de çok ciddi bir durum yani
sorumluluklar vardır bunu gerçekten o
tutkunun sorumluluğun Aşkın kavganın
gerilimin Hepsini bir arada olduğu bir
yer burası ve başka bir dil konuşuluyor
Bir de gerçekten mutluluk veriyor yani
hayat ama Bence herkesin olmayan Anılar
kalkmış oluyor cesaret katıyor bunu
yapabildim başarısı hissini Duyuyorsun
işte
yardım paylaştık bilmediğim şeyler
öğrendim belki birilerine Ben de
bilmediği bir şey yok ki
a harfi insanlarla olmak farklı
insanlarla beraber aynı fiziki olmasa da
aynı ortamı paylaşmak ve aynı şeyi
konuşmak hoşuma gidiyor böyle nasıl
desem yani yanındaki de aslında çok
hissederek işe yapıyor Sen de çok iyisin
bir şey yapıyorsun Yani bir sürü insan
hissederek yaptığı şey tek bir noktada
buluşuyor Keşke bir de
böyle tekrardan sahnelerde
Söyleyebilecek daha güzel olmuş konuda
olmak gerçekten ne ona veriyor birlikte
bir şeyler yapabilmenin beraber daha
güçlü bir şeyler çıkara bildiğinin bir
ortak bize iki dinlen Çok keyifli bir
şey anca başarı ayrı bir şey mi birlikte
şarkı söylemek bile çok güzel birlikte
bir şeyi aynı şeyleri aşka yapmak
isterim
bu
Günümüzün en önemli sorusu
yarın ne olacak hangi meslekler devam
edecek Ben ben hangi mesleğe sahip
olursam Acaba bir şey Arayacağım yani
artık teknoloji hayatımıza çok güzel bir
şekilde giriş yaptı bu pandemi
vesilesiyle de hepimizin hayatına Meta
borsten bahsediyoruz İşte bu robotlar
zaten çalışmaya başladı uzun yıllardır
dolayısıyla bir çoğumuzun kafasında soru
işareti var ne olacak evet birçok iş
kolu yok olacak bunu artık biliyoruz
yani Zaten göreceğiz 5-10 yıl itibarıyla
da Ama işte bir şey kaybolmayacak
bizi biz yapan şey
duygularımız hiçbir yere gitmeyecek ve
duygularımızı
bu ifade etmenin onlarla hareket etmenin
en önemli
yolu
sanatmüzik koro müziği İşte koroda o
Duygu birliğini sağlama öğreniyoruz ve
ne olursa olsun duygularımıza her geçen
gün daha da fazla sahip çıkmalıyız
Onları asla Es geçemeyiz artık çünkü bir
tek o kalacak ve o her zaman devam
edecek yavaş yavaş bu videonun devamında
izleyelim Sonra son sözlerim söyleyip
kapatacağım Yani kesinlikle buranın
içinde olmak Zaten acayip bir şey
herkesin Ayşe istedim aynı şekilde
hareketle bilmesin ama
benim
gittiğim komik rahatsızlığım var ve bu
dönem Benim için çok zor geçtim bazen
enerjim çok düştü bazen hissettim
kendime ama buradaki bütün insanlar
bilmeden benim elimden tuttu ve beni bir
şekilde devam etmeye sevk ettim
o kimsenin daha önce yaşamadım bir süreç
içinde bir rutini devam ettirmek bir
tanıdıkların olması aslında herkese
biraz da olsa rahatlattı Bence daha
böyle samimi hissettim daha böyle Yani
aslında Hayat Devam Ediyor Böyle
dışarıda böyle olaylar oluşan bir şeyler
geçiyoruz ama aslında bir şeyler yine
devam ediyor hala hayatında benim
bulduğum yerler var
sorunum öğretebilirim kızım
öğretebilirim yakınları öğretebilirim
öğrencilerim öğretebilirim Yani
gerçekten paylaşabileceğim bu kadar
düzgün bilgiler alıyorum sizden
Ya
ben acilde çalışıyorum ve Bu hastalık
bizi artık yani o katıyoruz olduğumu
hissediyordum ki artık sadece hani Yaşam
ve Ölüm benim için güzel şeyler de özel
sadece işe gidip geliyorum yani çok
yoruldum cimartesi nöbetten çıkıyorum
pazar ilk prova var diyorum elime tekrar
tabanımı aldığım her gün görüyorum bir
süre Giden insan de enerjik işte
Fotoğraf çektirelim resim yapalım yani
ben de İstiklal seçtiğim hissettim
Aslında genç olduğumu hatırladım
Çok mutluyum çok mutluyum yani hepsini
seviyorum diyesim geliyor Beni
sabah böyle Yanaklar Çünkü
o
işte bu yüzden Diyoruz ki biz de
kollarımızı sayısı artsın Türkiye'nin
her yerinde çocuk kollarımız gençlik
kollarımız
de basın ve çocuklarımız çoksesli
Korolar da şarkı söyleyerek yetişkinler
işte Az önce bahsettiğimiz insani
değerleri Aslında bünyelerine katarak o
değerlerle yoğurularak sevmeyi
paylaşmayı dayanışmayı öğrenerek
yetişkinler ve o çocukların oluşturacağı
toplum dünyaya çok daha farklı bakacak
emin olabilirsiniz İşte o zaman Bugün
olduğu gibi maalesef savaşlardan
kavgalardan değil aşktan sevgiden
barıştan ve kardeşlikten bahsedeceğiz de
bunu hep birlikte yapacağız Çok teşekkür
ederim hepinize bana eşlik ettiğiniz
için